herr bauer und mein name ist luca und
herzlich willkommen wir heute zu einem
neuen video auf meinem kanal meine
lieben freunde ist ja bereits im titel
eingeblendet der ich teste heute die
kapital grad hitze ihr wisst ja dass ich
riesiger pizza fan bin ich habe selber
bereits drei pizzen in kooperation mit
gustavo gusto rausgebracht von daher
würde ich schon sagen dass ich mich ein
bisschen auch auskennen mit pizzen und
ich bin wirklich gespannt auf die
kapital brad pitts aber ich habe so viel
von dieser pizza gehört verschiedene
videos über die pizza gesehen ich habe
auch schon ein zwei reviews angeguckt
und ich bin einfach gespannt wie die
schmecken wird ich werde die allerdings
nicht allein probieren sondern mit wachs
[Musik]
bush war drin nicht aber alleine reicht
da glaube ich dass ich eine reiterparty
man heute kapitel beraten müssen erstmal
durch allen leuten die überhaupt keinen
plan haben was überhaupt heute abgeht
erklären was überhaupt abgeht ich habe
es ja schon so ein bisschen im intro
gesagt wir testen leute die
kapitalbesitzer denn kapital brach einer
der bekanntesten rapper in deutschland
hat einen pieps herausgebracht wir
gleich zwei vereine mit linda salami
glaube ich exakt bisschen anders und ich
weiß auch nicht genau meine mit
grillgemüse das war ja genau den drei
eine vegetarische eine mit fleisch ist
also auf jeden fall alles verladen und
so und die gäste eine baracke kinder zu
garten platziert sich 38 bachelorarbeit
schreiben gefasst machen wir ein
bisschen mit einem bachelor arbeit ist
bisher ein halbzeiten er ist schon der
seite alltag rasse geschlecht alle
einmal bitte mit klatschen und kliniken
halbzeiten sehr schon anderthalb seiten
mehr als gestern das gewöhnlich kleine
erfolge feiern gerade wenn man über so
social media sachen schreibt finde ich
arbeite jetzt wenn das der fall dann
halt sofort wieder aus seinem eigenen
geben seine eigene erfahrung schreiben
was aber einfach nicht was man nicht
darf weil zeit nicht belegbar ist
irgendwie quelle aber noch man diese
ganze branche ist halt so jungs und die
finde es halt einfach keine passende
literatur das halt auch mal ein problem
aber es soll nicht einmal fest arbeit
gehen sondern
um den red carpet jetzt im revier
durchgekommen so ergiebigen die eine
großpackung man sieht mich aber ich habe
von anfang an dass die auch ein motorrad
deshalb glaube ich ist die normale was
ich eigentlich nicht so viel weil dort
trotz der ersten gangsta vier euro
das ist schon ordentlich also dass wir
uns da wusste der partner mit dem ich
die pizza gemacht habe ich kapiert
kaufen jetzt auf jeden fall gut und wir
müssen an der charakter ist gleich mehr
gold japan aufgefallen tatsächlich
alleine zwischen von anfangs analysieren
und haben gerade die 410 gramm was schon
sehr vieles aber die kapitalbasis mit
540 gramm also der preis gerechtfertigt
irgendwo auch ja auf jeden fall
und diese station mir um zehn euro der
kommentar von der dingen 200 km 119
jahre aber wer kapital pizza kaufen kann
der kann auch kissen und ein paar
sekunden später
tja leute einer hat vergessen dass
praktika zu entwerten ich weiß nicht
denn wenn wir haben die hashtags team kp
pizza mit grillgemüse gekauft und mein
gott als haltlos und creme fraiche drauf
klingt interessant auf jeden fall der
anderen fenster befindet sich
tatsächlich rinder salami und andrey
käsemix auch der die papiere in der
salami pizza die 4 142 gramm die
grillgemüse pizza bis zu 500 sich dabei
so 100er mehr
das heißt in welcher stadt ich glaube
ich auch mehr bock auf die muss ich
sagen ich habe eigentlich gerade gar
keinen bock auf twitter machen beide
gerade gefrühstückt längste rally ist ja
die marke zumindest kann man nicht
erkennen das ist ein komplett neues
produkt die haben sich nicht mit einem
partner oder so zusammengetan haben
komplett und produkt selbst entworfen
wenn ich es interessant universal music
gmbh aber so sieht die biz auf jeden
fall aus wenn man sie raus nimmt also
sie ist auf jeden fall würde ich sagen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das kabinett darauf 225 grad der
offenheit auch gerade schon vor für
normale größe der maler größte ja wir
sehen schon also sieht auch komplett
normal aus jetzt sie zum taktieren hat
diesem track pack die wahrscheinlich
schneller hat mit macht auf jeden fall
dieser scheiß für das auf jeden fall die
erinnert ich würde sagen die knallen die
jetzt mal 800 wir uns wenn die fertig
nur wenige minuten später der vorgang
ist beendet ladies gentlemen hier ist
doch nicht
erst mal raus stammt ja drauf vorne 25
grad zehn bis zwölf minuten beim 6 11
drin gelassen ne brauche ich gut sieht
man ja wir ballern direkt die
grillgeräte hitze auch reiniger ich hab
ich habe jede einzelne pizza so gemacht
und wenn du musst halt überlegen die
beiden pixel sind mehr oder weniger
gleich schwer also die rinder salami gt
440 ist und ich erwischt 410 das ist
gustav bewusst und das kapital braucht
man geht schon die sind von der größe
komplett unterschiedlich liegen aber
gleich viel
das heißt hier habt ihr so flachen teig
bisschen so fieldings und hier ist er so
ein bisschen lebkuchenmesser kann
einfach so das ist ja italienisch und
des american sind zwei komplett
unterschiedliche produkte auf jeden fall
aber den ball an grillgemüse rein und
test in der zwischenzeit ist denn daran
doch was ist da drin was müssen ja wir
haben keine andere wahl vorbereitet bin
zwar kein riesiger pizza salami immer
eher prosciutto metrisch wenn die
politik dies nachteile das richtig krass
beantworten
[Musik]
für mehr gespannt ich habe jetzt wieder
richtig hunger
doch setzt ja ich finde dieser rahmen
ist keine anderen pc-herstellern aber
schmeckt auf jeden fall gut schmeckt
besser als jan oder anderer andere
tiefkühlpizza nie vergessen was soll ich
sagen
und findet so gut ist halt eine komplett
andere abgezogen ja es halt nicht so
italienisch der rabatt runter du bist so
horn sondern ist bemerkenswert eine
gangster rap
man muss halt auch sagen pizzas generell
ziemlich also er bringt jetzt kein kino
a2 bei joghurt raus sondern pizza ja
geil finde ich auch gut dafür zu geben
auf skala von 17 bis 34 b 21 j glaube
ich okay kraft hinter sanitäter
aufgegessen
von daher komme jetzt zurück hat es auf
jeden fall schon mal ein bisschen größer
das ist die grillgemüse vom rein
äußerlichen sieht deutlich gesünder aus
aber mit dem ganzen käse natürlich
wieder mit drin
dreht der animation rein und ich haben
ja auch aufgegessen gerade noch aber
jetzt wollen wir uns die matt die plätze
auf jeden fall mal rein
also die plätze auf jeden fall größer
geworden dadurch dass wir die noch eine
minute länger drin hatten ihr seht ist
halt so ist auch dieser verbrauch belegt
mit extra viel
nein nicht belegt frage ich vergessen
folie also die haben auf jeden fall alle
insider irgendwie von kapital brauchen
wir sehen schon dass befindet sich dort
auf jeden fall tomate drauf paprika
zucchini mit test und der hand hitze
viel großer trend boden das geil ist mir
etwas zu dick zu viel tykwer der boden
des krieges richtigkeit zum wilden
schmeckt nicht so geil wie die rinder
salami aber trotzdem gut ist so guter
geschmack und schmeckt gut
kraft wird die so vom ergebnis her
guter geschmack und so von bestimmtes
level vom gaumenschmaus level würde ich
eher sagen guter geschmack probier mal
die werke peter plate nummer eins
nummer zwei ich bin ja mal war über die
auch ein bisschen kalt und ja ein
bisschen mehr so dick ist das ist nicht
komplett aber also selbst bestimmen ja
das stimmt bei mir war auch also die
weiß nicht doch die sache ist dadurch
dass der teig halt total dick ist es ist
heute teil schwer die komplett der vor
gesagt was wir denken so absolut noch
helfen aber die kürzungen drückten beide
noch ein bisschen kühlraum
was ich aber vor interessant finde ist
dieser hanf geschmack ja das habe ich so
gefühl noch nie gehört ja ich finde
jetzt nicht unbedingt schlecht es ist
nur ein neuer geschmack ist wirklich so
dass ich sage schmeckt viel schlechter
als die rinder seien habe ich finde es
gut aber ich finde auch die idee gut
dass jetzt zwei verschiedene pizzen
rostock hat einen patch day erinnert war
mich hat's drauf kommen können aber ich
bin echt positiv überrascht muss ich
wirklich sagen hätte ich nicht erwartet
dass sie so geil dass ich bin selber so
ein test und esther dabei das ganze
stück doch vorhin verfassten jeden 27 j
ja ich würde gibt zumindest gala wie ich
bewerten soll
seit ich würde sagen knoblauch ja ja
okay wenn du dich entscheiden müsste
zwischen kapital pizza und im neuen
namen geben
das ist schon schwer katze hat auch hier
sitzen kaufen und dann die daraus ein
auto bauen
dann würde ich ketchup nehmen ich hätte
mich eher für den tannenbaum entschieden
aber jedem das seine von märkten und in
die kommentare schreiben
die pizza schon gegessen habt ihr schon
sie euch max rund in der beschreibung
verlinkt regelmäßig videos
also ich unbedingt bei ihm vorbei macht
das die letzten zehn wörter 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 10 für nichtig hier können jetzt
hier mal den kanal abonnieren oder hier
unten meinen job ausschenken jetzt
findet ihr zwei andere videos und wenn
ihr schon abonnent seid könnt ihr auch
die glocke klicken dann willkommen die
benachrichtigungen
[Musik]